welcome to this joint overview and
scrutiny committee I'm
counting may I first remind you of some
domestic arrangements please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use and if you do not interrupt other
speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones and
laptops are on silent
additionally we will be using the
e-voting for this meeting on the modern
gov app
I would like to remind everyone
president present
though we're not all presidents just yet
everyone present that this meeting will
be broadcast live to the internet and
will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
we are joined today by Mark M director
of operations and Jack Burton Finance
business partner for the item on public
realm and by Jan Robinson corporate
manager for Law and governance and of
course Alicia Norman our lead officer
for overview and scrutiny
can I move to the agenda please
apologies for absence and substitutions
thank you chair this morning we have
apologies from Council Act pingong
to receive decorations of pecuni other
vegetable or non-registerable interests
by members
any
nope
none received right
to confirm the minutes of the joint
meeting held on the 20th of February
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of these minutes
nope could I have a proposal please
thank you
the governance officer will conduct the
electronic vote
thank you chairman chairman vote is now
in progress
we've got everybody
councilor Grandin can I take your vote
verbally
councilor Lindsay can I take your vote
verbally as well please
thank you that's right you don't get too
much thank you chess that makes nine
votes four and two abstentions so that's
carried
thank you
I mean it's a joint meeting on the 20th
of February been confirmed
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
questions by the public
unreceived
questions by councilors
none received yet thank you
item seven the information bulletin
review of current levels of untreated
sewage discharges to Waters in baber and
mid-suffolk
this item has been deferred to the next
joint overview and scrutiny committee
which will be on the 24th of July 2023
this decision has been made at the
request of the agencies due to attend
the committee to answer questions on the
item this is to allow them time to
finalize the compilation of all 2022
data on sewage discharges and water
quality which is due to be finished in
early April 2023
I think it's important that if we're
going to look at this data this
situation
and put forward some concrete and
workable
suggestions then we have all the
information up-to-date information
available so I think it's important that
we do defer this until the AP until the
July meeting
I think there will also be a new chief
executive of the environment agency by
that time as well because he's just
being replaced
councilor Lindsay
yes it just it sounds sensible chair
um
just wanted to
ask if it could be if not the only item
of business on that day at least you
know the the agenda not be too heavily
Laden with other things that day
because it's going to be quite a big one
so
and I probably won't be there but it's
important it's scrutinized properly I
think we are all in that sort of
situation of we're not sure whether
we're going to be there or not but we
will certainly um I'll ask the
governor's officer to make sure that the
agenda isn't heavy on that day so that
there's
maximum amount of time can be given to
the subject
item eight on the agenda information
bulletin a review of the impact of
bringing public realm in-house
I'd like to invite the director of
operations to introduce the information
bulletin to the committee
thank you very much chair
um so yes as requested I've answered uh
well tried to address answering the
questions that were raised in the last
ons meeting so I've provided a bulletin
to answer this question we've read the
content of the bulletin with chairs and
this is a review of the insourcing of
public realm Services into baber from ID
Verdi you'll recall this this committee
looked at that when actually at the time
looked at the various options that were
available and commented on them for
cabinet to make their decision and
um really it's looking at whether the
insourcing is delivered its objectives
and whether this can be determined to be
value for money for the council or not
really and happy to take any questions
on the bulletin that are provided
why they're not here
regard the portfolio the cabinet members
portfolio overseeing all this so I had a
number of questions regard to
communication which would quite like to
put to them and they're not here I'm
from either side I don't think is there
a reason why
realm and
reason for the vocabulary if you have
some specific questions for the cabinet
member of the public who is responsible
for public realm and certainly we can
forward them on if you'd like to make we
can certainly forward them on
thank you on that point I was going to
make make that sort of similar comment
it's a shame that the cabinet members
aren't here
um it's always appreciated when we do
have them they they often do do attend
um and it is a a re-endorsement of the
importance of scrutiny and the relevance
to the work of the council so I think we
should make a comment back to cabinet
that we do expect cabinet members to
come along when we're doing this
important work
or both councilor I was born and myself
attend cabinet meetings to put points
across the cabinet and we're always
asked if we've got any questions on the
items on the agenda Etc so certainly if
you
forward me the the questions I can make
sure that they're put to the cabinet
next time there is a cabinet meeting
it's not a problem and also the comment
about them attending all the relevant
person attending
attended
thank you very much Mr chairman
um
in regards to asset depreciation in in
um it says um that
that's um the depreciations calculated
over seven years first question is um is
that just vehicles
um and is that depreciated to zero in
those seven years or to a level where
you could sell the vehicle on
thank you
yes I'm happy to answer that thank you
councilor Kasten
um so for the purpose of just vehicles
um it's over the useful life there's no
expectation of any residual value on
disposal so it's straight line method so
not in the first year of acquisition so
12 and a half percent reduced over 80
years to a zero value
obviously is we don't get taxed on the
income and so forth of what we earn from
public realm then if there is a resale
value at the end of that then that's a
bonus for us
yes councilman Barrett thank you
um
and uh good morning
um I'm I think I recall when we were
talking about HRA account
um I don't know if you were here Mark at
that discussion but there was talk about
those tenancy those public areas
maintained to a higher standard like
the queried at the time
um
so is that reflected in the contribution
from the HRA and is that correct
um yeah I remember the conversation as
when we were scrutinizing the general
budget and the HRA budget as well and I
think the point of difference really is
that we were talking about maintaining
the HRA
locations to a higher standard than they
are currently being maintained we do not
want to create
here so set of Standards between the HRA
and the general fund but we did accept
that the HRA assets have been under
invested in in terms of the amount of
time we've been spending on them for a
bit of time really and that was that was
a legacy issue of when it was outsourced
under the idea of early contract it's
come back into the council's Direct
Control under its dla operations and
time just to get on top of those
standards really and part of addressing
that has been to address the recharge to
make that accurate to the value of works
that's been taking place
councilor Allen
yeah thank you chair
um going back to earlier points about
cabinet members I I feel that we should
have a formal recommendation at the end
of our discussion back to cabinet
back to all members of cabinet under the
leader that we do expect to see cabinet
cabinet whether it's in the whether it's
in the cabinet
oh and a scrutiny protocol or not I
think I think it is reasonable to expect
them and there are many
um scooters in in some authorities the
only people to speak at scrutiny are the
cabinet members and they have to deal
with all of the questions so when when I
was at some Central training uh we heard
we heard this from several authorities
that they felt really sort of having to
be completely on the ball when they
attended scrutiny because they had to
deal with everything
um and
um if I may say so I think cabinet
members get off pretty lightly here
um both authorities
um
but anyway so I would like that to be a
formal recommendation
um
one I've got a number of points and
questions
um one was that when we debated this a
long time ago one of the concerns
um both sides had concerns I think baber
had concerns about the the one-off cost
of sort of joining in with the
insourcing but uh
a mid-suffolk members had had concerns
that oh dear will we get a less good
service and will it cost us more
there's no evidence of either but I
would just like to be reassured that the
service that was being provided
pre-in sourcing a favor is is the same
as it you know there has been no
reduction in service and no increase in
cost
um
another thing that we were asking about
at that time was uh there was a
discussion about the possibilities of
some sort of diversification extra
services and one in particular that we
we discussed was around tree surgery and
emergency situations and prior
I guess prior to the insourcing and
development of the service
contractor had to be called every time a
tree fell down basically
um
so are we now in a position where every
time a tree falls down we've got
somebody with a chainsaw who can go and
deal with it if not is that a situation
that you would be able to
um is to sort out
and and the big the big question hanging
over all of um
the work that you do for housing is
is the data that you're now collecting
accurate enough broad enough sufficient
enough for a really accurate recharging
because we have had big concerns over
the years
that uh general fund is rolling in money
particularly at mid-suffer and the HRA
account
doesn't it's not in the same position so
is there anything more that needs to be
done anything more that can be done to
make sure we've got accurate data
I think that's it for the present um
that may have a follow-up question thank
you
okay thanks thanks for those Council
what am I think I'll just try and run
through them and picked a few questions
up there say
um firstly
mid-suffolk wise we there's been no
reduction to any services in mid-suffolk
as a result of the insulting
um so at no stages frequencies or um
level of service or resources going in
actually changed on that so from that
perspective it hasn't I think the team
would argue that you've now got a more
resilient service because you've got
more managers that can cover each other
in the event of absence and then
initiatives like um biodiversity that's
come on with the nation who's coming out
just before this transfer happened but
during this period it's been better
supported across the two councils where
you might have experienced higher costs
and more impact on a service if you were
just supporting that sort of initiative
across one Council
from an agriculture the the tree surgery
perspective
the short answer is we don't have a
dedicated agriculture team climbing
trees
up roped climbing cutting cutting down
trees into that we do a lot of low level
tree works we do a lot of tidying up
works and trees come down limbs have
come down we can tidy that up clear
roads clear Pathways that sort of type
of work
um it's something we might look at but
it's based on the economics and the
volume of whether there's enough work
there to justify um cost and the risk
obviously climbing tree climbing trees
is quite a risky activity working at
Heights with chainsaws it's not
something that we couldn't do some
councils some service arms with councils
do do that and
to make those type of services
economical they also trade those
Services commercially as they're doing
that as well so that's something we're
not doing at the moment but we might
look to do
um and then I think the final question
was around housing data and how accurate
is that at them at the moment we've done
an accurate re-costing a
um what I would say is a total cost
collector level so we've reviewed our
services looked at the number of
the resources that we've got working on
the service so people Vehicles equipment
time other service costs that are going
in there what we haven't done is break
that down to a scheme bus game level so
that it can be accurately
recharged to tenants from the HRA
service itself the reason why we haven't
done that is yet at the moment is
because we need more accurate mapping
data on the ground which is a project
we've got two offices working across
both councils updating the cad Corp
system with GIS data so we're expecting
to get on top of that and get that
completed later this year and I know
that it's something I've had discussions
with my colleague Deborah Fenton
housing about how we get that accurate
information so it can be recharged
because if she's Keen to accurately and
fairly recharge tenants for the for the
work happening in their schemes and it
does vary a little bit scheme by skin
um it's sort of a follow-up question you
mentioned well you mentioned trading of
services
um is this something that you do you can
do you might do I mean thinking in
particular of
um
kit like mow and collect and so on there
are a lot across the districts there are
a lot of groups that are
trying to grow Wildflower Meadows and in
particular I think you've got a machine
that's based in Stone Market which is
some Parish councils have used I believe
or
has been offered to
is is this something that you could
expand is it something you want to
expand and perhaps advertise because
there's there's no way that
a lot of parishes are going to be able
to to deal with their Wildflower Meadows
in the in the in the best possible way
without having access to you know the
real best Machinery thank you
um I think the short short answer is um
yes we we might be looking to trade that
at the moment we're undergoing a big
change we're
um on the on the baby side we're
recovering the standards up to the
standard level that it should be I've
not I've not kind of tried to hide away
from that in the paper and the response
that I put forward there's been a bit
pitching up from the
um the previous contractor and we've
just just completing really the First
full Financial Year's worth of doing
that and we really feel we'll get on top
of that going forward this year and at
the same time as that the one of the
core activities that we're doing as part
of our biodiversity action plan that's
been set up is we're converting what we
sort of classify as various grades of
amenity cut grass over to um Meadow
grass and Wildflower Meadows where it's
where they're actually suitable the soil
conditions and and the areas suitable
for that as well and we're getting a lot
of interest from
um different town and Parish councils
because
um of course at the same time they're
also looking to see how they develop
their own biodiversity action plans and
what they're actually actually doing and
we're trying to work much more closely
with other town and Parish councils to
assist them in the best way possible to
do that it might be through more
machines it might be through different
machines I'm challenging the team to say
um we can't just have more machines we
have to be more you know Farmers don't
go and buy 10 combines and have them all
sitting there so they can work during
Monday's Friday at certain hours of the
week yeah we need to expand how we're
going to work and cover this at these
busier times of year but of course we're
also experiencing a growing season that
is longer and certain sites um I'm
reliably informed by our biodiversity
manager can be cut at different times of
the year it doesn't have to be a single
cut to call it the end of the you know
the traditional sort of end of the
summer so we're looking at all ways of
doing that um
same time as we're we're in the
background fleshing out our plans a lot
more around biodiversity as well
Council Grandin
thank you Mr chairman
this might seem a minor issue but it is
certainly one of the things that in
summer I as a counselor get contact
about all the time and that's grass
cutting
you've sort of mentioned
it's in a sideways way just now but not
all areas of recreation or grass
um are suitable for
um Meadow
work
so can you tell me last year it was
slightly improved
on previously
but it wasn't really the the sort of
magic
um change that I had been hoping for and
I still received complaints from
residents
um can you tell me plans going forward
because
um I think our changed weather
conditions are now meaning that the
grass seems to grow
it seems to flourish more
um but are we responding to that and you
know I have residents who have shared
communal Gardens
um
in sheltered housing and so on where
they can't use their Gardens in summer
and couldn't last year because it wasn't
being dealt with quickly Enough by
Beaver but also the parks
were not looking sufficiently better
from this point of view and
we can't turn them over to Meadow you
know they're used for picnics and
playing football and so on so can you
tell me the plans there please
um yes thank you
um
well of course one of the one of the
benefits of bringing the service
in-house is sort of flexibility as well
and something we have experienced is a
low
quite rightly that I'm first to put my
hand up and say yes there are issues in
places and there have been and we do get
complaints and we react and we deal with
them and we
proactive with the first flex piece of
flexibility you have is to decide how
frequently to cut the grass when the
grass isn't growing as much like it was
last year we had more specimen weeds to
deal with and the grass wasn't growing
quite so much because the dry conditions
whereas in an outsourced arrangement
from a value for money perspective the
contractors course is still taking the
council's money and not doing the work
and finding something else to do with
staff or just not backfilling those
staff when they're away and they're off
and taking the benefits of that we're
we're actively reviewing our grass
cutting rounds at the moment as as we do
and should do every season so that
involves getting the the crews in who
really know about that as well and where
to cut the grass the mapping work that
we're doing is also contributing towards
giving us better information to plan
that and I've certainly
um I've certainly tasked all the teams
with
um reviewing those grass cutting
schedules so that I can actually look at
them and review them before the start of
the season and we will have the
flexibility with the resources being um
to try and increase the resource levels
or decrease the resource levels if the
grass isn't isn't growing so much we do
have the Machinery we will have more
resources and staff particularly to help
us as we know in housing and since the
annual budgets were agreed we've moved
very quickly and are about to start
appointing staff in public realm and
ground so they will be will be available
to work as the grass now start starts to
grow as well and of course you know when
we do miss something or it's something's
missed off the schedules we did try and
react quickly and respond via the
customer service channels available
which is better under an in-sourced
arrangement than an outsourced um
Arrangement as well and looking a little
bit further
um a little bit further down the road
the work that we're doing on the mapping
and the work that we're doing on the
scheduling producing the detailed rounds
and scheduling we're also looking to um
tail that work with a piece of work or
mobile working so that the crews will
who are now starting to use smartphones
and tablets as you can imagine that's
been a a familiarization and training
exercise to to work
cruise to get them up to speed on that
we're expecting we will have a situation
where we'll get positive confirmations
that an area has been cut and and that
will feed back and to the center and
we'll we'll have that information
available as well so
um
something we've missed please keep
pointing it out I'm not I'm not sitting
here trying to defend that hasn't
happened in the past but
um I like to from what is being fed to
me and from what I'm seeing is we seem
to be going in the right direction to
travel
yes because I'd like to I'd like it to
be that we don't get the calls
um you know that it's
it's all preempted and you know
programmed by yourselves rather than us
having to keep um regularly reminding
public realm that an error still hasn't
been done or whatever
so yeah I mean that sounds that sounds
promising I hope I hope it will
and because I think also what what um
seems to happen now is that we might
have a period where the grass doesn't
grow and then all and then all sudden
the weather changes and it shoots up but
the response isn't there and I know
that's really hard for you to to Monitor
and it might not seem a big thing but to
our residents it is a big thing
it's it's difficult
um you know as we know we've
with with
rain with the sun and you know the
growing can you know the grass can flush
and it can grow quite quickly and when
you've got a grass cutting cycle that's
sort of set up
um
kind of go around in that cycle and
suddenly we can be maybe 10 days off for
or more getting to a particular site
that isn't necessarily per se a problem
in itself but if you then missed a site
or there's a problem in that and that's
double the length then we get that to we
get that
yeah
um we're expecting to see more positive
Improvement again it was our first full
season really last year since
um since transferring back from back
from Ali Verdi and you know we feel
we're getting a
took control of it now I wasn't here to
witness the standards under Heidi Verdi
um you could you know many of you
obviously were and you can maybe
um contextualize what that was versus
Under ID versus now which is um
what I suppose I'm generally trying to
answer here but I do I do accept these
points and we want to become much more
reactive in all our services alone I've
got plenty of examples even just this
last week if we are reacting to all
sorts of things
thank you very much
well the Council of Willem essentially
um asked my question which was about the
um Wildflower Meadow mowing equipment
and I think that was a really good
question to ask and I thank him for that
there is a huge demand for equipment as
specialist collecting equipment for um
for dealing with the Wildflower Meadows
and town Parish Council there's also um
farmers are looking for people that can
do that kind of um do that kind of um
operation on it but um
so
maybe my question is where we we
obviously have some operations that we
need to do which
um are ones that we don't do very often
and we have to get contractors to um
come in and do it that's that's got to
be in part of this but is there any um
scope for
buying an asset between many authorities
for instance drain Rodding
um lorries or that kind of equipment and
talking to other authorities and getting
one bit of equipment that serves maybe
the whole of Suffolk I think it might be
drain Rod it might be a bad example
because we might do very little of it
but um it's um I just wondered what the
scope was for that and also the scope
for actually having assets that contract
privately when we're not using them
to um yeah
thanks um yeah I I I think I think
they're both valid points and I think I
think this scope for
um both of those sort of um both of
those type of suggestions really as well
I've been around long enough to see
um certain assets and certain specialist
services like Gully sucking and drain
clearance kind of
um get actual cut because of the
frequency they were actually getting
used and then outsourced the contractors
um same some of the other cultural
services and different things as well so
yes
um certainly pairing up with other
authorities
um where Suffolk maybe or Ipswich as
well to work with to say is there scope
for either sharing equipment or having a
contract on some of that with a
contractor here we might have a little
bit more clout with if we bring our um
bring our Outsource contracts together
on some of that I think
um I think makes sense uh aspirationally
I'd like to trade trade the services but
I'd want to do that from a strong base
and make sure that we are delivering
delivery great Services which are
excellent which are meeting the needs
and I know we've got a challenge around
a challenging housing as we look to
improve and assist Deborah we're moving
towards a drive was excellent in that
area
completely overstretch the team as we
bring that in but we should be planning
now for say a year ahead or so because
these things don't happen immediately
to bring papers to gain support back
through your sales cabinet Council Etc
and we should be working that direction
but I think it's I think aspirationally
looking at is good for
good for public realm team and good for
other teams because it allows them to
grow the size of their
um
part of the organization it also exposes
them to work in for customers other
customers rather than just residents as
well and that sometimes helps to sharpen
up practice that's going on as well and
make them more
competitive and efficient so I do see
that as part of our
model really to be honest but we're just
not quite there at the moment
Council Baron
thank you um I'd like to just talk about
road sweeping
um as you know Mark I'm being I've been
looking at that especially in Sudbury
where I live
because it it had really built up in
some areas it was obvious that some bits
hadn't been swept for a couple of years
at least
um
so I know that you have
um said you know that some areas some of
the main routes are swept more more
regularly what about the other routes
that have cars parked on them regularly
what are your measures to to try and
um get those those areas swept
well my focus at the moment with the
team has really been on
um resourcing and making sure that we've
got the resources fully staffed out each
day and
our utilization and uptime on vehicles
being used during during the working
week and we're improving on that we did
inherit a
set pool standards really from the from
the contractor where several routes many
routes hadn't been getting swept at all
and that has taken a lot longer
particularly through this first full
season to try and get on on top of the
team reassures me that we are
utilizing the the equipment of vehicles
we have
um a free-fold increase over the prior
contractor but that's still not enough
really and so we've been addressing some
core issues like
um making sure we've got enough
qualified class 1 hdv drivers to drive
the larger sweepers
setting up cover Arrangements within the
current staff base so that we have got
some other other members of the public
realm team that have got class one
licenses but setting up so that they can
get paid an acting up allowance so that
they are getting paid the same as the
sweeper drivers and rotors for that and
availability for that as well so that
we've been trying to make sure the
vehicles are going out we've also had
some long-term sickness to deal with
with some of the drivers at the same
time as well which we've had to be
mindful and compassionate of how we deal
with that as well but essentially we
will be looking to get the network swept
much better than the moment obviously
there's always a focus on certain
primary roads in certain Town areas but
I would like to get it into a position
where we can get
published routes effectively as well in
the future so that people know where
we're going to be sweeping we've
realized this coordination and
integration issues with areas
particularly with parked cars and that
can cause some issues and optimistically
in the future we want to mechanized
sweeping needs to be coordinated with
Crews on the ground as well that can try
and be sweeping in some of those air
problem areas and linking our systems up
to do that we're not there at the moment
they're just being totally honest but
we're seeing improvements all the time
and
uh didn't it start improving going
forward now that we've got the
resourcing levels right really on it
that could be the first set of
improvements and going forward as well
we are looking at um
we're looking as well as we
coordinate these rounds and schedules
more about putting mobile devices into
Vehicles so that any driver that then
jumps into the vehicle into seamlessly
take over really to be honest and that's
an option that we've been considering
with the system
in the same system for that we have
actually we're about to bring that white
space mobile encap system into some of
the collection bin collection rounds for
um
bins and
dog waste bins as well so that will
start to help in in those areas so that
we don't end up with Miss bins and we'll
look and see if we can bring that in and
Roads we're being a few
in a few cancel doors
and you've got your microphone on
to take back all the
um
in-house we were going to have one and a
half man a mini someone was going to go
around on a mini tractor with the
fertilizer
on their backpack and Blitz the whole of
beaver and mid Suffolk now to my
knowledge that never really happened and
it slightly concerns me particularly
with the coronation coming up people
want to see sort of Tidy streets in the
towns Etc as well as the villages
so was that plan shelved or is it still
ongoing for this year and if so when is
it going to be happening in the areas
where there's larger numbers of people
because it's
really noticeable how bad it is but I
realize formally that's a County
but we were meant to brought that
in-house at the end of last year
um apology I don't know the answer to
that I'm afraid I can I'm happy to bring
the answer back it's not something that
um I can't recall as you know I've been
here relatively short time but I can't
recall having a conversation with the
public realm team on weed spraying or
what was agreed last year I do know with
weed spraying there's usually
um
there's usually issues over whose
responsibility is between the county
councils and ours but by the sounds of
it that discussion was one that was had
and we were looking to see if we could
bring some um control over that back
in-house I know I know our approach to
read
um as well as weed spraying I know we've
got
um the Ripper units which you swap out
on the
um street sweeping vehicles on the
medium-sized and smaller Vehicles as
well that have been going along and
ripping weeds back out of the
um
the Gully waves as well so that I know
that's been going on as well but I'm
happy to take that question back and
respond on it yeah yes and if we could
have a schedule
um for the towns particularly when it's
going to be done because I don't believe
you know for about three years actually
was done
thank you
Council Lindsay
thanks chair
um
can I I just make some observations and
then ask my questions and it'll be
obvious
why I'm asking the questions
um
I'm really excited by the fact that
we've now got
I mean it sounds like a lot 23 000
123 square meters of grassland has now
become managed as Meadow
um when you work out how much that is in
acres it's nearly five which doesn't
sound like a huge amount when you do it
that way
um
the um
we have got a biodiversity crisis we
don't see insects
um some of us will remember in our youth
coming going on Long Journeys and seeing
your windscreen splattered with insects
that doesn't happen now because
everywhere everyone expects a green
micromanaged sort of Immaculate
Multicultural green sword
um
all right so I feel like our Parks don't
have to be
um you know people cancel the ground and
refer to people once it's a picnic
um if I'd rather if I was having a
picnic I'd rather have a chance of
seeing some butterflies and some bees on
a picnic rather than a few flies which
is all that's left when you just manage
a a field and mow it every every day and
we kill it and all the rest of it
um I think we need to encourage our
residents to accept that if they want to
have some insects they want to see the
birds they need X and if they want the
insects we need to manage our grassland
a bit more lightly rather than
expensively mowing every month
um
so I think I think we that's where I
know it's a particular problem if you if
you're a counselor in a town residents
will say why isn't this place moaned
like it used to be and I think we do
have to push back a bit as leaders in
our community and say well you've got a
choice here do you want do you want to
restore biodiversity
um or do you just want a perfectly Green
Lawn which is actually a desert
um
so and the same applies I'm afraid even
for
um you know going around blasting
everywhere with glyphos glyphosate I
think we our residents have to at least
a toxic
chemical to the ecosystems and to humans
um the County Council is
next year will cease all use of
glyphosate
um
I I don't think I think we need again to
encourage people we need to tolerate a
few more weeds we eat our wildflowers
and we need to learn to tolerate them a
bit more apart from anything else it's
much cheaper for us as a council
um and there are ways that we're part of
our I sat on the biodiversity panel and
we were looking at ways
and we talked about getting rid of
spraying and with with pesticides like
glyphosate and the idea was to use
um
mechanical weeds are putting ways of
pulling up the weeds or a um a a way
that's um environmentally friendly that
doesn't use pesticides so you know the
talk of vinegar was being used so I
don't I don't know what's happened with
that but that was the plan I remember
that the biodiversity panel discussed
and agreed
um so I'll now get to my questions
[Music]
um
do we have a target for the the total
amount of grassland that we'd like to
become the percentage of our grassland
that we own that we'd like to
um become managed for Meadows
because I feel that even in Parks you
can mow a small strip people want to
have be able to walk through you can mow
a bit but you don't have to mow the
whole the whole park
um
so do we have a Target and where are we
on that
um
could we or is there are there any plans
for a kind of marketing Communications
plan
to encourage acceptance
um that their our grass would be a bit
higher there would be more flowers that
would be more dandelions because they're
to Feed the Bees East Suffolk has a has
a a program like that it's been stand
quite successfully sort of council
um
and but when we were talking about
getting a some doubters when we're
talking about getting a cut and collect
mowing machine on the biodiversity panel
there was a people were worried about
but what do you do with the you're
collecting the cuttings what do you do
with them where do you put them so I
just wonder if that has been a problem
or not
thank you
okay thank you thank you for those
questions yeah um I think I think the
short answer if you spoke to the public
realm team
um in general I think um I think we all
want to go much further with
biodiversity and we'll be bringing
um address strategy for biodiversity
back we just started working on it
actually in much more detail we have a
biodiversity action plan for both
councils and with General observation on
that we would be we're ahead of the
targets on the action plan but the
targets on grass cutting as you know
there's not much really really relating
to it there as well
um
I think
you know we do we we want to we want to
increase the the level of meadow grass
cutting it is a challenge we're working
with that we want to go much further
there is some signage going out on on
areas but are we doing as much as
formally trying to Market that as a
campaign or doing that as much as we
should maybe we're not this this signage
going out but that could
um that could happen as well in terms of
biodiversity strategy we we want to
cover off you know why we need a
strategy that the legislation and policy
that we're trying to address which is
coming in from government which would
you know us and town and Parish councils
are going to have to work um work on
we've been doing a lot of work
internally we're planning
um preparing and working with them on
biodiversity net gain they know they're
going to have to bring that in later
this year so there's a lot of internal
work in that's been going on with there
because changes to supplementary
planning documents and biodiversity Net
game requirements are going to be a huge
benefit
there as well and we we really want to
look and address opportunities to work
much more closely with Partners working
in our area Wildlife trust and there's
many others that are way further on this
journey than what we are and we can
harness their expertise and work closer
with them and participate
um more widely with the county councils
develops its local nature recovery
strategies as well there's plenty of
funding out there that we can attract to
do this
and get these get this change that we
need to happen through but
um
I I feel as well that we do need to
manage it in conjunction with what we're
changing from and what we're going to
and there are still some
um there are still some requirements for
more formal recreational areas for
members of the community to enjoy in
different ways but there's no reason why
that can't be alongside
um Wildflower planting and Meadow you
know Management in in those areas as
well
um so yeah I I don't disagree with
um
anything that's been said they're ready
to be honest it's just gonna and I think
we're we're better we're
British but I suppose the the general
question on
bringing the service back in-house from
an outsourced contractor it's clearly an
easier position to be in when we're
delivering this ourselves to to achieve
our teams and changes and be more
flexible than with a contractor who
would say that doesn't exist as part of
the specification of the contract can I
have some more money please or not be so
you know interested in it um as we are
ourselves obviously
data work we know we've got some really
good data on where all our trees are now
as well and that's helping to Target and
inform the strategy of where those trees
get planted with the right tree in the
right place
um I just feel probably we've got to do
a better job of saying what we're doing
marketing what we're doing and working
more effectively with town and Parish
councils and yeah
um four or five acres of matter under
management doesn't sound like a massive
area when you change it to that there's
lots
see that I'm comprised of that and we we
work on each of those sites uh preferred
option is not to have to take the
risings away anywhere because it costs
money to dispose of and it doesn't
doesn't make sense so we we try and find
to um install the grass cuttings in and
you can turn that into a compost on site
or with or we're increasing biodiversity
by storing that on site as well then we
looked
we looked at buffets just massive
opportunity really to be honest and I
think we can do that in a way that
keeps everyone happy we work together on
it
Council Carter
thank you
um regards going back to the vehicles
and you mentioned about possibly putting
the mobiles in in place uh would that
not at a possible Target for vandalism
or fever where people where they've had
this issue in
um not answers but to be it makeshift
for evidence to be and they had them in
place and they were targeted for vandals
with people trying to rip out the if
they would that not put them at risk for
people trying to Target them and another
question going slightly different
um mentioned by councilor Grandin
um regards not all areas being suitable
for Meadow grown and also mentioned
rather more length
councilor Lindsay
um
I I will say that's possibly uh for
um care homes or things like the meadow
grass growing may not be suitable one
thing we've mentioned before uh well
I've certainly mentioned it replacement
with
low growing UK native tapestry mixes
now these if you have mixes of daisies
you have mixers with Clover not only are
they firmer and make easier for movement
for if you have a Mobility to scooter or
a wheelchair if I make a lot easier to
actually move about in they need cutting
far less frequently
and they also be Clover especially it
draws in the a lot more carbon from the
atmosphere puts it into the root grounds
and actually can be used for making
nitrogen fertilizer and also for seed
mixes for feeding wildlife feeding
animals which we've mentioned many times
in the past it's being looked into and
then we hear nothing from it so wouldn't
it not a lot be possible to look into
this and actually implement it because
it'd be a lot less work for a ground
sting having to go to these areas where
there's maybe you need to do once a year
to be trimmed up
it's more work employment learning needs
scarification needs to be turn upside
down and then needs to be grown upwards
but it wouldn't be worthwhile putting
the effort in at the start and then
having a low maintenance less work from
going on for my place onwards
uh thank you face uh thank you for those
questions yes so the the first question
um mobiles in vehicles mobile working
um we don't we don't consider it would
be an issue of being targeted it's not
something we hear across the industry of
it being a problem something like the
the vans that are collecting the the
bins obviously refuse Freighters all got
mobile devices in in them already
drivers
the vehicle I know
collecting the litter bins and the dog
bins you're not far from a vehicle doing
that or street sweeping you're kind of
in there whether we put in terms of
mobile working in the pickup trucks for
the rest of the public realm team we
typically deliver that via a small via
an app from mobile working on on their
smartphone it's something they're
probably then keep with them so it
wouldn't be in the vehicle so I don't
think that would be so much of an issue
there
um suitability of Meadows and planting
yeah that's exactly the sort of
detail and investment we need to be
making going forward
apologies obviously I haven't used the
fact that I haven't been here haven't
had that challenge before I I do
understand and know that
turning a piece of amenity grass into a
wildflower Meadow doesn't just happen
and needs to be plowed up and replanted
and and looked after and it's a bit of a
myth thinking it's less work involved in
in doing that it's just different work
at different times and front loaded and
and it's really typical I suppose of the
the scale of change that we're
undergoing in in our area of public row
and the industry I suppose as well to to
raise you know our game and answer the
um challenge I draw us back to saying in
in the question here that we're better
in-house to be doing it than we are to
be trying to Outsource that and I feel
we're now getting into the position
where we've um recovering the standards
that we've inherited particularly in
baber and we can start going further and
start um actually
um you know in investing and making this
change happen and changing this in the
service and and I think it's it's not
just about Meadow cutting we need to be
much more ambitious and look at
um uh look at taking on on board more
sites there's quite a bit of
um activity going on with in planning
and different sites that are likely to
be coming our way from adoptions and
that's something that the team also
looks after and does giving its feedback
in there and that's ideal opportunities
to get the design of those sites right
right from the start really to be honest
with working with the developer so it's
not something that we've got a
change over and not something we've got
to do and we've been having a lot of
um a lot of input into that because
we've we've got a specialist technical
biodiversity manager in the team that's
working across both
um districts and and that is starting to
starting to have some benefit I think as
well
thank you
I got Council
[Music]
left to speak so we'll start with ladies
first Council Barrett
very much um one quick question then a
broader question mark
um is it your intention to
um operate the sweeper five days a week
ultimately
should I do my second question before
it's
um I my my area that I
um District councilor for is along the
border with Essex so viewers and Neyland
and and obviously living in Sudbury as
well so bordering bordering Essex
um
was
can happen is that those areas right
close up to the Border can get a little
bit sort of um forgotten because they
are out the outlying districts of our
our area and we can sometimes and then
what happens is the your opposing
numbers in in the other Council also
leave a sort of strip that is is a bit
neglected um it's no man's land is it is
there any liaison or
um with your neighboring council's
um or on on sort of uh lit litter or or
maintenance at all
so two areas yeah um so um from a
sweeper point of view yes we'd look to
be operating that five days a week
um
it might be possible to operate it
longer than five days a week I'm not
going to commit to that but ultimately
ultimate principles would be looking at
the
when I'm when I'm happy we're managing
the services as optimally as we can then
you start to look and say how can we
utilize the equipment better than we do
at the moment and is there a cost
benefit case for doing that so um
clearly you don't want to be sweeping at
night and waking people up I'm not
suggesting that for one second on the on
the um border issue um this is some
informal dialogue and conversation that
goes on I'd say it's more suffix Centric
than looking South to Essex um but
there's no reason why it shouldn't be
looking more south to Essex as well
um and I'll certainly I'll certainly
pass that back and also pass back the
specific issue of um crossover on the on
the border and we should just regardless
we should be making sure that
um
all of our district proportionally gets
um some of the attention that it
deserves
yeah we're we're you know we're aware of
some of the um
seasonal impacts of tourism in the south
of baber District particularly or
whatever like that and
um areas of outstanding natural being
the pressure that visitor numbers brings
as well and we we work with we do work
down into Essex there with colleagues
particularly on other matters Guardians
sort of a car parking enforcement and
stuff as well
so I'm not accused of being misogynistic
or anything like that councilwale
thank you chair
um last summer there were some real
successes uh around changes to Mowing
regimes and one that I was partly
involved in was in Cedars Park in
stowmarket not in my pack but in Dave's
pad and um Terrace's patch but uh
is involved in that because it was it
was Verge it was County it was district
and so on Richard Palmieri did some
really good negotiating that but we
never we never sought to get any uh
compliments for it so I think we've done
some really good work and we really need
to let people know that it's the
district council is that our staff who
are who are making these changes
um and I think that's really important
um
uh Mark you made the point about cut and
collect I had the I was fortunate in
spending half a day with supper Wildlife
trust out in style Upland just a few
days ago and one of the points they made
was about cut and collect and how we
don't we need to cut it we need to
collect it but we don't need to take it
off site and there's a lot of advantages
in that for protection for vertebrates
and the invertebrates so
um and that's something which I think
people need to know about
um and I feel that there that we need to
get parish councils and others more on
on board
um talking with separate Wildlife Trust
in many areas the parish councils are
the most difficult people to convert and
it's certainly the case in Stow Upland
where I asked for no more may for this
year and they said oh no Prince Charles
wouldn't like it for his coronation
people would want to go out and picnic I
thought well Prince Charles is probably
the one person in the country who would
be really pleased
um but you know I wonder if there's
scope I'm not suggesting that you
arrange at such workshops but for
to set up workshops for parish councils
and others
and so that the message gets over that
yeah we all we all want to do the same
thing but Parish councils need to know
what we want to do and what residents
want and they need to get on board thank
you
my own parish for instance has it pays a
litter picker
to go around the village and also
opportunity manages the sports grounds
where of course you can't turn those
into a wildfire Meadow otherwise the
football is right and the cricketers
might complain and just to correct you
councilor well it's King Charles not
Prince Charles he was elevated to to
being King on the death of his mother
I apologize I apologize to our key thank
you very much chair uh yeah Parish
councils are very very different
um and there are you know there are some
Parish councils doing really really good
good work and yeah we need we need them
to be on our side we need to let people
let other parishes know what what can be
done thank you
um well yeah it's just I'm agreeing I
find myself agree again
um certainly we need to improve our
Communications
um about biodiversity in general
um we've got a great comms team doing
some really good really good work at the
moment and there's going to be lots of
opportunities there for us to um improve
in that area we're starting
win awards for the likes of the tree
pieces of tree work we did as well with
the tree data and stuff so I'm sure we
can get further comms on the back of
that as well and yeah working with
others to improve there's lots of
knowledge out there for us to gain from
including Suffolk world
so trust obviously and others but we
need to work much more closely with um
town and Parish councils and
biodiversity is much wider than planting
trees planting Hedges converting
immunity cut grass over to Meadow grass
and then some of that Meadow grass into
Wildflower Meadows
but when you look at our biodiversity
action plan it's not much why there are
some other activities on it as well it's
been
is great to get going but actually
that's one of the reasons why we as a
team now feel we're doing some of that
but if we're really going to make a
difference we need to kind of present
much more of a strategy of what we're
doing going forward and then hopefully
um
that is something that you feel you
build to support if you're in that
position to do so in the future for us
please
cancel Grandin
thank you Mr chairman
um a couple of points I'd like to make
please
um returning to the maintenance of our
parks
um I think there needs to be different
strategies for different places which I
hope you're probably doing
um for example in in one of our main
parks in Hadley Cox Park it's known
nuclears
um
last year it was cut in the main areas
and then the areas around the outside
where trees are growing that was left to
grow wild and I think that's
completely acceptable
but the main area that people used to
walk and play ball games and so on does
need to be cut a strip going through I'm
afraid wouldn't work I think we do have
to think that public parks in the main
and there may be exceptions and that's
for you and your strategy to look at
each Park
and and examine how it's used
um would need to be the main
you bit that people use would need to be
cut and having a script going through of
um was suggested by my colleague I don't
think would work in in four public parks
um so so that's but but you need to have
a strategy and see what works in each
each place which as I said I hope you're
doing and the other thing I just wanted
to ask is we've heard a lot on the news
lately about Sheffield and Plymouth
where there seems to be a strategy of
cutting down mature trees
can we be assured and I would hope that
this might go down in the minutes that
such such
actions will never happen in our in our
councils because
that was the most shocking appalling
situation in Sheffield it's been going
on a long while I understand
um I hope there will never be any
excuses to do anything like that in our
districts and I I would hope you can
assure us
um that that will never happen in in our
districts please
I'd certainly not want to be cutting
down any tree that
um
be taken down for reasons of sort of
health and safety effectively it's the
only logical reason that that we've got
or
um if the we know that there's
damage to damage to the tree or disease
to the tree that's likely to result in
um
part of it falling over a branch coming
off we've got to
um to managers of trees in our service
one works more with planning one works
more directly in our service and I know
we do a lot of
safety inspection and work on on trees
to prevent that sort of thing from
happening but certainly no we would we
would not want to be cutting trees down
we're trying to plant more trees and
across across the packs really and to be
honest as much as we can and get the
right tree
um in the right place one of the
particular areas we we struggle to plant
trees is in the urban environment we
know that there are lots of benefits to
having trees planted in towns and that's
something that we're going to be looking
to um
we double our efforts to work with the
county and highways that they've got a
new contractor as well and trying to how
many more opportunities we can get to
try and get some more more trees into
our Urban environment they are more
challenging they are more expensive to
put in in the right way
some massive
beneficial
thank you very much and I believe um
plain trees go very well in urban
environments
um
this has just reminded me of something
that happened because there's a lot of
talk about this biodiversity and I
understand that your director of
operations and you're not corporate
manager or public realm but um before
um or just at the start of covid me and
another
um councilor councilor Pratt
after the um biodiversity work was done
we sat down and um we mapped out every
single mid-suffolk owned area in every
single Village in mid-suffolk
um and designated it whether it was
suitable for planting fruit trees
rewired in Wildflower Meadows and
everything and like that we basically
saw that there was three different types
of land that we owned we've got um land
that's suitable for rewilding Wildflower
Meadows or um fruit trees there's land
that needs to be kept cosmetically good
though um the benefit of a small area of
cosmetically managed grass is um
absolutely nothing compared to a large
area of
biodiversity project and the other bit
was places where access
infrastructure needed protecting for
safety reasons we would have to be
pretty ruthless with things growing
especially where disabled access and
things needs to be maintained
um
it was a really good bit of work it got
it so covered was there I remember it
went on people's doorsteps and they
looked at it I also shared um a lot of
the
um the sites with the um Ward members
for that so that they could know what we
had identified but
people have changed positions and um the
um and um I wonder if that work has just
been lost now
it's um I've still got the original copy
in my um in my desk at home but um it
would be a real shame because it seems
to me like there's three ways of
managing different
there might be five there might be 50
but for Simplicity it seemed like there
was areas that we must not put
glyphosate on I think those first two
the Cosmetic and the um and The
Wildflower sort of designated sites
shouldn't have it but sometimes we might
want to consider whether it's the right
thing to use where infrastructure will
get damaged where slabs will get pulled
up by um by roots and things like that
and people with accessibility
um issues won't actually be able to use
the facilities but um so there is a
question here so how much of that do you
think is actually
been I know the um the person
responsible left
um The Counselor you know a before
that that could have gone in but whether
that was that work was passed on because
we did spend hours and hours and hours
um during um during lockdown just
pondering over these sites and
discussing things on the um telephone
and that so um
have you seen any anything of that or do
we want to revisit it or or maybe look
at look at adapting it so it's something
that can be used in public Realm
um I I have seen some evidence of it
actually as well so whilst my role is
director of operations and you know and
unfortunately will couldn't be here
today but
um yeah I've seen evidence of that I
like because I've seen sat down over the
shoulder of um our offices that have
shown me mapping on screens where
they're showing that these areas are
mapped as Wildflower Meadows and these
areas are mapped to where the trees have
gone in and planted their biodiversity
manager um Richard palmy I've heard him
talking about
um talking to me about schemes in areas
where there's been planting of fruit
trees going in in that as well so
um anecdotally I've heard bits and
pieces as a formal delivery against that
piece of work that was done I don't know
what's still there and or not and
whether that is specifically being
reported on but I know
um from from what you're saying there
elements
talking about there and I think
um it sounds like it'd be a waste not to
make sure that wasn't captured and I'd
um I'll have a conversation about
biodiversity manager Richard palmier and
I'll probably welcome yourself and
councilor Pratt having a conversation
with him as well to see where
um where we've got to on that
Council of Muller
if we can take this one as the last
question I think oh sorry cancel the
Carters I would like to totally concur
with um councilor Wellen uh what you
were saying about Cedar's Park I live on
Cedars Park
um and I did have the opportunity to
meet up with Richard palmy last year
um well I had several complaints about
the rewilding but also a lot of positive
comments about the rewiring and I would
say generally the positive
comments outweighed the negative comment
I personally was in favor of it I
thought was really good
um and I I think a really useful
exercise but going on from that we've
identified a couple of areas on Cedar's
part where we could plant some more
trees
spoken to a couple of the residents and
I've actually written to your colleague
in public realm this morning to see if
that can be um taken forward I think
it's really really important for
biodiversity and and hopefully that will
be the case thank you thank you
thank you
um very pleased to hear about not
wanting to cut down any healthy trees
I'm sure Stone Market will be most
really relieved you'll be targeting any
walnuts but um
uh regards to be Road sweeper that's
going to be out five days a week I would
be a mess not to ask
um how is that fueled because there are
councils who have Electric Road sweepers
Aberdeen is to be First Council to
actually have fully hydrogen Road
sweepers are we looking to be purchased
in making sure we've just done our bins
in our bin collection
which was
nice nicely received it's been quite
well are we going to look to do the same
for all our vehicles so what our Fleet
to try to make it bring down the carbon
emissions and if we are looking to be
purchasing more I hope we're going to
have a new renaming competition I was
very sore that mine didn't get picked
you know I'd quite like to see a
sweeping mcsweet my face but you never
know
I'm sure the team would consider a
naming competition should that happen
because obviously there's a lot of scope
with um street sweepers um the same same
as refuse rators
um I will check but I was under the
impression that the road sweepers were
also being fueled by hva which is
available out of both Depots as well
where the where the road sweepers are
actually actually based
um yeah so okay and the in terms of
um future fueling of those types of
vehicles we we need to consider what's
right
um a few weeks ago I attended the
um East um he Suffolk these tougher
coasted hydrogen conference over at um
lower stuffed and um yeah hydrogen is
coming as a fuel source but it's not
available for us to
readily tap into at the moment I don't
feel um particularly on the on the road
road sweeper side there or the all the
Refuge um refuse for each Fleet side
um we would consider
oilfield sources and the most
appropriate alternative fuel source at
the next time of replacement for any
vehicle and also part of this discussion
is also tied into
um infrastructure to allow for the for
the refueling to take place as well as
contract management as a part of that
sometimes as well and as you'll be aware
we've got
um we've got commitment for funding
subject to a full business case being
developed and accepted by um both
councils to look at developing and
bringing forward plans for new Depot
Depots and we'll be looking at that
those new facilities there in terms of
how the refueling would work so do we do
we put a combination do we allow enough
space for hydrogen refueling and
bunkering on site do we or or biogas if
it was biogas or put in the connections
for
sustainable electric to be coming in
enough space for battery charging to be
on site for the solar panels which we
have on the reef Etc and we're looking
at all those options as part of that
project really to be honest but yeah
depending on where in the country and
what access has been to different
feeling arrangements and capital
available you know we're aware different
councils have already moved in that
field
thank you very much indeed for for that
presentation from over all the questions
I have to say that from my own personal
point of view 40 years of working in the
immunity and local government sector as
far as grass and amenity areas
maintenance is concerned I've seen quite
a few changes you mentioned Aberdeen I
think councilor Carter well I can
remember when I went to Aberdeen on one
occasion and I was
it was explained to me why they only
grew roses down their central
reservations
and that was because it's the only plant
that would tolerate the levels of salt
that they put on the roads so everywhere
is different
so one of the wonderful
traveling around the country
everywhere is different
for us I can also remember when paraquat
was
was commonplace
not just in suicides but also in killing
weeds before glyphosate came along so
things keep moving along the whole time
and we just have to keep up with them
thanks very much yeah
uh sorry chair just one final Point here
as well
um will birchall can be with us this
morning but he's helped um unfortunately
he's attending his dad's funeral this
morning but will has helped
significantly to put together
um this paper and I just like obviously
I've been here a few months but I just
like to record my thanks for what Will's
done for the service over the last
couple of years because I was involved
in
um from a consultant point of view of
the decision to bring it back in
in-house and putting that report
together but
um I'm really pleased in the position I
am now
um of the hard work that Will's put into
turning things around really
thanks very much indeed now this paper
is for noting but councilor Willem did
suggest should I say a rather request
that perhaps we should put a
recommendation
uh forward to cabinet
councilman yeah
I totally agree with what character
women well have raised earlier that we
should perhaps make a recommendation
that it would be helpful if the cabinet
members could attend these meetings in
future so if that was a proposal by
Council wear them earlier I'm happy to
second that at the moment
can I just jump in actually in the
con there is already
for that so the portfolio holder should
be invited along I think it's more about
our processes and tightening up because
it was an information bulletin we need
actually at the chairs briefing to just
tighten up who we need to invite so
there is provision already in the
Constitution so I don't think there's
any need for a recommendation
so I think stamped in large print on the
Chairman's backside will be something
which says look more carefully at who
should be invited to the meeting in
future so we can make sure the cabinet
members are here
all right
councilor I don't know if we want to add
with this that um I'm really impressed
with what's going on here I think this
is a the this is the right direction I
think babe we're making a good decision
to bring that in-house and um also this
is a really good way of realizing our
biodiversity Ambitions and um getting in
a position where we can increase them
and we can make them stronger and
stronger as we go on so um yeah I think
thank you very much
for what you're doing and yeah really
pleased with today's meeting
thank you um I do agree we we need more
uh World letters but in town centers
they're not really suitable and yet we
still want to increase
the range of biodiversity so I think
actually we need to add to that that the
other areas can be cultivated in time
centers they don't have to all be little
tiny little patches of grass which we
have done in in my um Street in in
Sudbury and it has improved the uh birds
and bees and butterflies enormously just
in one area so it doesn't always have to
be a wild Meadow to achieve that
fair to say there's a vast range of
different plants that can be utilized to
increase biodiversity and they can be
put into small areas whether it be
shrubs or just bedding plants or
whatever something to increase the
biodiversity that way but it's going to
be different for each area because both
councils are primarily rural areas
yes we have population concentrations
but they're they're different from the
rural areas and it makes a challenge for
the public realm team even greater in
terms of trying to meet the requirements
of the different types of areas
I'll be content though to Just note this
Castle Dawson um yes it's supposed to
also make the recommendation going
forward I mean I've asked this number of
times I do think that um
shadowy cabinet
I'd like to see a schedule the
continuation which I did of a monthly
schedule of actually what's happening
with iverty just as a note because that
really was so useful and I have to say
in the last five months that's not
happened and that way we can all sort of
keep on top of what's happening or
what's not happening but certainly in
the last few months that's probably
because you're new I don't know whether
you're aware of it they always used to
do monthly updates which was distributed
to counselors and
um
I'd like to see that um had a game
uh it's it's not something I've been
made aware of but so the public realm
service would send a monthly update no
out to all counselors were they
I will distribute it there's a
PowerPoint that's done every single
month so the number of dog bins as you
empty what streets you're doing where
you're fertilizing is really very very
efficient and I've not seen that the
last five months and I I would highly
recommend
that you uh your cabinet member for
environment must see it at her monthly
briefing
if she's going to those I presume
yes well I think we're all gonna
there'll be considerable changes uh for
the next time I had to have a monthly
update I mean it was very efficient I
thought
if if you can send me a copy of the last
update that you received please then
I'll take up where that came from and
when it was last made and and how that's
happening and whether it's something we
can but I think continue a number of
Departures maybe
um it's got lost you know with Cass
leaving will leaving
um so there we go a lot of the people
have all left so it may well have just
got
um but I would have thought each month
you're briefing the
um Cabinet member and therefore when you
brief her he was provider with that
information
hopefully from operations yes so a
summary of that would be useful again to
have for all members I believe
certainly was for me
Council Osborne you have a point to me
sir thank you Mr chairman yep um just on
that point uh I think every portfolio
holder has meetings with the
representatives uh the officers of that
particular
item that is being dealt with by that
group so
um yeah it is done so I I know that I
would just like to say that um
as I'm aware of particularly in Sudbury
the changes that have been carried out
since the in-house set up I agree with
councilor um
accustomed yeah
the counselor on my right
and there's been you know it has been
excellent and it the I'm afraid that the
problems that we have with our last
incumbent in in
Realm
has
I'm afraid been
you know they didn't do a lot at all but
this from my perspective from where I
have looked around Sudbury the road
sweepings are done things are getting
done headies are getting cut at the
right time where they weren't being
dealt with before so I'd like to
congratulate our director of operations
and the
the information bulletin that he's
provided I think it was excellent thank
you very much
thank you Mr chair
right so for no more comments on that
that report was for noting
we have also noted the fact that uh we
will be making sure that the appropriate
cabinet minister a cabinet minister
Cabinet member is invited to the next
over to the appropriate overview and
scrutiny committee meetings
so if we move on to item nine on the
agenda which is the overview and
scrutiny Committee Action tracker this
again is for for noting do members have
any comments
yeah thank you chairs well it's on page
29 just a couple of comments
um
the the top panel there are there are
three items there which are not started
um and on the face of it looks as if
people have been doing what they should
have been doing but I think the first
two
um the toolkit and the training session
I think we agreed that they should be
prepared ready for the May new member
training so it's not as if they haven't
been started I'm sure that there are
there are officers who are preparing
them so I think it's unfortunate that it
says it's not started um but members
won't see anything any outcome until
well only those who are re-elected will
see any outcome but I think that work is
going on the one thing I would query is
1.7
um because I'm surprised that we haven't
had any feedback
there was a strategic assessment carried
out by the County Council into
um the community safety department
and
I think all we needed was to have some
information from that
perhaps just information relevant to how
to districts but we haven't we don't
know whether that information is
available it would be useful to know at
least if it's available
um and if not
well one because it ought to be I guess
it ought to be a public document
um
you know it may be a public document
people may have access to it we just
need to know whether
we can be provided formally with that
information
it probably won't be a worry for me in
May but it it might be something which
is useful
before the the June overview and
scrutiny
committee and that brings me on to the
last point which is
um that uh
uh June is traditionally a level field
security meeting the first of the four
years it's usually a training session
um so will that go to the June committee
or will the whole of the June committee
be taken up with training
um
or can the training be outside of a
public committee and the first so that
that training could be carried out
before the June overview and security
committee meeting which would then look
at Community safety partnership
offices particularly asked for that to
go to the Geo committee and we agreed
so where we are with that I think it's
just a dates need to be sorted I think
so chair just to clarify
um we are obviously looking at the
training induction program for
councilors at the moment the plan was to
use the first dates for the Committees
to do some training because obviously
cancers can't sit on the committee until
we've undertaken some sort of training
and then dedicate the first meeting to
work programming
so um we were going to push this back to
um the first of the you know the July
meetings
um we did we have been having
conversations with officers about
whether
um that would still be appropriate so
a census was that it it was
um and we did I think there's been an
email out to chairs to say about the
training and for the first few sessions
which I think I thought you had agreed
but um we can take that out just on the
other stuff the toolkit and the the
training session that is in hand and
will be part of the cancer induction
program so that we can actually say that
that has commenced
if that means that the community safety
partnership review is moved to July
it takes
it takes up a whole morning does the
review of the community safety
partnership
and I think the review of the situation
in respect of sewage in rivers would
take up a whole warning so
there needs to be some re rethinking of
the programming workplan isn't on the
agenda that's why I'm raising it now
there needs to be a rethinking of that
to make sure that both of those two have
a fair amount of time yeah and um yeah
through you we can always obviously um
you know convene another additional
meeting if we need to but that's the
discussion for the new chairs once we
know who they are in May yeah
no other comments on the action tracker
well that concludes the business for the
for today's meeting but I would just
like to say thank you very much indeed
to all of you for your your efforts
during the course of the time when I've
been joint chairman of this committee
I wish you all the very best at the
elections if you're standing
and for those that are outstanding enjoy
the retirement
see how many how
of us appear at uh
of the unscrutiny meetings thank you
very much indeed